A police officer suggested that congresswoman
Alexandria Cossio Cortes has deserved,
you'll be shot and called her a vial idiot.
And the term of the day for this story is
to Catholic terrorism. That's really the story
here and I'm going to get to that. The officer's
name is Charlie pally. According to a Louisiana
publication, he has been on the Gretna Louisiana
police force since 2005 and he posted to his
Facebook page quote, this vial idiot needs
around. And I don't mean the kind she used
to serve, of course, referring not to a round
of drinks. Alexandra Ocasio Cortez used to
be a bartender, but rather to a round as an
ammunition. He's talking about bullets. She
needs a bullet is what a police officer is
saying. Ah, the police chief says it's a disturbing
post and if accurate, it does violate the
police department's social media policy. But,
and here's the thing I want to focus on. The
police chief says it's not an actual threat
against Alexandria Kazuyo Cortez from the
police officer.
Presuming I guess that the police officer
means I don't believe the police officer is
likely to find and shoot Alexandria a Casia
Cortez. And that's what I want to talk about.
We can talk about all the obvious stuff. The
cop should not be on the police force. How
do you trust this guy to keep your neighborhood
safe? If he has the poor judgment to suggest
on the Internet w under his name, under his
real name that, not that it's any better to
do it anonymously, but I mean it shows sort
of like a lack of judgment as well to think
it's going to have no consequences to suggest
publicly that a member of Congress be shot.
We would all mostly agree that even if you
don't like AOC politics, uh, this guy shouldn't
be suggesting she be shot. She shouldn't be
shot. And a police officer in particular saying
that, uh, is wrong and should be removed from
the police force.
Let's focus though on this isn't a real threat.
Okay. This is really important. This type
of defense might make sense until you are
enlightened about stochastic terrorism. I've
talked about this many times before. I think
this even came up on my Joe Rogan appearance.
Stochastic terrorism is when someone goes
and commits a crime, they commit an act of
terror, a shooting, a killing, whatever they
appear to have acted completely alone. They
are apparent lone wolves, but in fact they
were influenced by a broader movement or an
ideology that they weren't personally in contact
with, at least not in terms of like a two
way communication. So if I have a TV show
with a big audience and I rant and rave every
day about someone's gotta do something about
AOC and some guy that watches but doesn't
know me personally, starts to think it's a
good idea to do something about AOC.
And then that guy goes and does something
that is a stochastic terrorist. I'm not legally
guilty as the host, at least not under current
law, but my statement to an audience when
the audience is big enough becomes statistically
more and more likely to influence someone
to actually go out and do something like this.
And right now it is the president who is doing
this. So understand the cycle here. Trump
Ranson raves about the un-american bad congresswoman
who hate the u s they should go back to their
quote, original countries. People at a crowd
react by literally chanting, send her back
about one of those congresswoman Alon Omar
in that case, and the defense that we heard
from the writers, they were literally saying
deport her. It was more symbolic. It was,
we disagree with her agenda. Well it might
be all fun and games except now here's a cop
influenced by this entire anti AOC apparatus
and he goes and posts on Facebook.
AOC should be shot the defense from his own
police chief. Well, the comment wasn't okay,
violates our policy, but this is not an actual
threat that the police officer is going to
find and shoot Alexandria Ocasio Cortez personally.
But then someone could go and see all of this
stuff and then really go and do it in real
life because that's exactly how stochastic
terrorism works. By fomenting this environment
where these ideas are repeated in more and
more places. Not only do we hear it from the
president, we're seeing it even from our local
police. I mean, look at all these people that
think something should be done. Maybe I should
be the person to go and do it. The perpetuators
of the rhetoric can hide behind a microphone
or behind a fake, a social media page or behind
the supposedly a symbolic nature of the statements
and say, it's hypothetical.
This is not advice to anybody, but statistically
you have to understand it's the Catholic terrorism.
You are increasing the chances that someone
goes and really does shoot someone. Am I saying
it should be illegal to have a show in which
you say something needs to be done about AOC
because somebody who is arguably potentially
unstable goes and does something? No, I'm
not saying that this is not me. Uh, repressing
speech or suggesting speech, be repressed
or suppressed in any legal way. What I'm saying
is these ideas that we can just dance around
with Khoi language and then say it's all symbolic.
It's hypothetical. It's just another way of
saying we disagree with her policies and hiding
behind that. It's absolutely ridiculous. I
saw Dilbert creators, Scott Adams, who I've
interviewed a great defender of Trump doing
this on Twitter. He said, no one is literally
suggesting sending a lot Omar back to Somalia.
This is symbolism and politics that all the
rhetoric being normalized actually puts people
in danger and it should stop. It needs to
stop right away and we need to call it out
clearly for what it is. We'll see what ultimately
happens to this police officer. I don't know
what his future holds, at least not based
on the sort of, uh, mealy mouth, uh, comment
from his police chief.